Ich werde dir etwas über einen sich drehenden Ball beibringen, nur dass es kein Ball ist und er sich nicht dreht. Heute bei Qiskit in der
Classroom werden wir über diese Quanteneigenschaft namens Spin sprechen, indem wir das Experiment betrachten, das als erstes Hinweise darauf
gefunden hat. Willkommen bei Qiskit in der Classroom. In dieser Serie nutzen wir Qiskit, um einige grundlegende Konzepte zu erkunden, die häufig
in Kursen zum Thema Quantum Computing behandelt werden. Jedes Video wird auch von einem interaktiven Modul begleitet,
das in der Beschreibung verlinkt ist, also schau da unbedingt rein. Heute sprechen wir über das Stern-Gerlach-
Experiment von 1922. Es ist eines der berühmtesten in der Geschichte der Quantentheorie, weil es so deutlich zeigt, wie Quanten-
Spin funktioniert. Aber das war nicht das, was Stern oder Gerlach zeigen wollten. Das Experiment wurde entworfen, um ein neues Quantenmodell
des Atoms zu testen, das Bohr-Modell, benannt nach Niels Bohr, der es 1913 vorschlug. In dem Modell bewegten sich Elektronen um
den Kern in diskreten Orbitalen, und sie konnten zwischen diesen Orbitalen wechseln, indem sie Photonen
absorbierten oder emittierten. Jedes Orbital hatte einen quantisierten Drehimpuls, der ein ganzzahliges Vielfaches einer winzigen Fundamentalkonstante war,
die h-quer genannt wird. In den 1910ern und frühen 20ern war die Quantenmechanik brandneu, so neu,
dass sie noch nicht einmal Quantenmechanik genannt wurde. Also waren nicht alle vom Bohr-Modell überzeugt. Ein Physiker
namens Otto Stern hasste es. Er nannte das Modell Unsinn und drohte sogar, die Physik aufzugeben, falls Bohr
Recht behalten sollte. Stern war so entschlossen, das Modell zu widerlegen, dass er eine geniale Methode ersann, es zu testen, und
Walther Gerlach rekrutierte, um ihm beim Design und der Durchführung des Experiments zu helfen. Es stellte sich heraus, dass er Bohr nicht widerlegte — er
widerlegte sich selbst. Ihr Experiment war so einfach und die Ergebnisse so eindeutig, dass es die
Debatte praktisch beendete: Quantenmechanik herrscht auf der atomaren Skala. Was sie damals nicht erkannten:
Sterns und Gerlachs Experiment fand auch schlüssige Beweise für den intrinsischen Spin eines Elektrons, was eine
neue fundamentale Eigenschaft der Natur war, die wesentlich ist, um Magnetismus, Supraleitung und einen Großteil der
Chemie zu erklären. Heute führe ich dich durch die Funktionsweise des Stern-Gerlach-Experiments, was wir klassisch erwarten würden
und was Stern und Gerlach tatsächlich gefunden haben. Dann zeige ich dir, wie du dein eigenes Stern-
Gerlach-artiges Experiment mit Qiskit und einem IBM Quantencomputer durchführen kannst. Die Grundidee des Stern-
Gerlach-Experiments war, einen Weg zu finden, um festzustellen, ob der Drehimpuls eines Elektrons in einem Atom quantisiert war, wie
Bohr vorhergesagt hatte, oder nicht, wie Stern erwartete. Sie nutzten die Tatsache, dass der Drehimpuls des Elektrons auch ein
kleines Magnetfeld um jedes Atom erzeugen würde, also kannst du sie dir als winzige Stabmagnete
vorstellen. Das Experiment sah so aus: Es gab einen Ofen voller Silber-
Atome und ein Magnetfeld mit dem Nord- und Südpol
hier. Das Feld war oben stärker und unten schwächer, sodass es einen nach oben gerichteten Gradienten erzeugte.
Schließlich gab es einen Schirm. Im Experiment erhitzte der Ofen Silberatome, bis sie verdampften, und dann
flogen sie aus dem Ofen heraus, wobei die Ausrichtung des kleinen Stabmagneten jedes Atoms völlig zufällig war. Dann passierten die Atome
das Magnetfeld. Die Atome wurden nach oben oder unten gedrückt mit einer Kraft, die von der Richtung des
Nordpols jedes Atoms relativ zum Feldgradienten abhing. Dann trafen die Atome auf den Schirm. Stern und Gerlach konnten schauen,
wo die Atome auf dem Schirm auftreffen, um etwas über den Drehimpuls der Elektronen zu erfahren. Stern erwartete, dass die Atome
sich im Experiment so verhalten würden, wie ich sie bisher beschrieben habe — wie winzige kleine Stabmagnete, die den
Regeln der klassischen Physik gehorchen. Klassisch könnten diese kleinen atomaren Magnete in jede beliebige Richtung orientiert sein, also
würden sie beim Durchqueren des Magnetfelds eine Reihe verschiedener Kräfte erfahren, die sie je nach Orientierung nach oben oder unten drücken. Ein Magnet,
der in die gleiche Richtung wie der Gradient zeigt, würde eine große Kraft nach oben erfahren, in die entgegengesetzte Richtung eine
große Kraft nach unten, und wenn er irgendwo dazwischen liegt, wäre es eine schwächere Kraft. Wenn der Magnet des Atoms
senkrecht zum Gradienten steht, würde er keine Kraft erfahren und einfach geradeaus weiterfliegen. Wegen dieser
Bandbreite möglicher Kräfte sollten die Atome alle an verschiedenen vertikalen Punkten auf dem Schirm auftreffen. Das Muster, das sie auf
dem Schirm machen würden, würde ungefähr so aussehen. Aber das ist nicht alles, was Stern und
Gerlach sahen. Stattdessen sahen sie zwei völlig getrennte Kleckse von Atomen auf dem Schirm, ohne Atome in der
Mitte. Sie hatten damals nicht die richtige Theorie, um das zu erklären, aber wir wissen jetzt, dass sie das sahen, weil
jedes Elektron eine gewisse Menge an intrinsischem Drehimpuls in Form von Spin hat, der immer nur einen
von zwei Werten annehmen kann. In unserem Stabmagnet-Bild bedeutet das, dass es nur zwei erlaubte Orientierungen der atomaren Magnete gibt. Wir nennen
diese beiden Orientierungen Spin up und Spin down. Ein Qubit in einem Quantencomputer
ähnelt diesem Typ von Spin-System, und einige Quantencomputer verwenden tatsächlich Qubits, die aus den Elektronen-Spin-
Zuständen bestehen. Also können wir unser eigenes Stern-Gerlach-Experiment mit Qiskit und den Qubits in einem IBM Quantencomputer durchführen. Lass uns
den Spin-up-Zustand des Elektrons auf den Null-Zustand des Qubits und den Spin-down-Zustand auf den Eins-Zustand
des Qubits abbilden. Als die Silberpartikel aus dem Ofen kamen, hatten sie zufällig orientierte magnetische Momente. Wir
können das Stern-Gerlach-Experiment modellieren, indem wir einen einfachen Quanten-Circuit mit einem einzelnen Qubit erstellen, das im Null-
Zustand startet. Das hier wird Circuit-Diagramm genannt, wobei die obere Leitung das Qubit ist und die auf das Qubit angewandten Operationen
als Boxen auf der Leitung erscheinen. Die RX- und RZ-Boxen sind Quanten-Gates, die
effektiv die magnetische Orientierung des Atoms drehen. Wir können hier zufällige Theta- und Phi-Werte wählen, um das
Qubit um einen zufälligen Betrag zu drehen. Das ahmt den Ofen nach, der die Atome mit zufälligen Spin-Orientierungen ausspuckt. Die graue Box ist
unsere Messung. Sie sagt uns, ob das Qubit im Zustand Null oder Eins ist, und sendet diese Messung an ein klassisches Bit, die
Doppellinie mit der Bezeichnung C. Dieser Teil entspricht der Messung, ob das Atom Spin up oder Spin down ist, indem man schaut,
auf welchem Fleck es auf dem Schirm auftrifft. Wir können ein Qiskit-Primitive namens Sampler verwenden, um das Experiment viele Male durchzuführen, jedes Mal mit
verschiedenen zufälligen Werten für Theta und Phi. Nach 100 Stichproben erhalten wir ein Messhistogramm, das ungefähr so aussieht:
50% der Zeit wird das Qubit als Null gemessen und 50% der Zeit als Eins. Das ist das gleiche Ergebnis, das Stern
und Gerlach sahen. Es ist immer entweder Spin up oder Spin down, aber nie dazwischen. An dieser Stelle denkst du vielleicht: Na ja,
natürlich bekommen wir zwei diskrete Ergebnisse. Wir haben das Experiment auf einem digitalen Quantencomputer durchgeführt, der immer nur Null oder Eins zurückgibt.
Und das stimmt. Aber denk daran, dass der gesamte Grund, warum Quantencomputer binäre Ergebnisse liefern, ja
warum Quantum Computing überhaupt funktioniert, genau diese Spin-Quantisierung ist, die Stern und Gerlach zuerst entdeckt haben.
Die Qubits in IBM Quantencomputern basieren nicht auf Spins, aber viele andere Quantencomputer schon. Also ermöglicht die Durchführung eines
Stern-Gerlach-Experiments auf einem Quantencomputer, dass wir die Spin-Quantisierung tatsächlich wiederentdecken.
Seit 1922 wurden unzählige Erweiterungen des ursprünglichen Stern-Gerlach-Experiments durchgeführt. Diese Erweiterungen bestehen darin,
denselben Atomstrahl durch mehrere Stern-Gerlach-Apparaturen zu schicken, um zu sehen, wie sich die Spins in verschiedenen
Szenarien verhalten. Hier ist eins: Schicken wir die Atome durch eine Apparatur, um den Strahl in zwei zu trennen, entsprechend einem
Spin-up-Strahl und einem Spin-down-Strahl, und schicken dann jeden dieser Strahlen durch seine eigene separate
Apparatur. Mit Qiskit sieht der Quanten-Circuit für dieses Experiment ähnlich aus wie der letzte, aber mit zwei
Messungen statt einer. Hier haben wir die zufälligen Drehungen, die den Effekt des Ofens nachahmten, durch ein
Gate namens Hadamard ersetzt, da das Anwenden des Hadamard uns die gleichen Messwahrscheinlichkeiten gibt wie der Ofen,
aber es ist viel einfacher zu verwenden. Also messen wir einmal und dann ein zweites Mal, und das
resultierende Messhistogramm für das Experiment sieht so aus, wobei die Bitstrings auf der X-Achse den
Ergebnissen der beiden Messungen entsprechen. Wenn das Qubit beide Male als Null gemessen wurde, entspricht das dem Bitstring 0 0, oder wenn
es zuerst als Null und dann als Eins gemessen wurde, entspricht das Eins Null, und so weiter. Es sieht so aus, als ob es, wenn Spin up im
ersten Experiment gemessen wurde, auch im zweiten Spin up sein wird. Gleiches gilt für die Spin-down-Atome. Das bedeutet, im ersten Experiment
hatten wir gleiche Wahrscheinlichkeit, up oder down zu messen, aber beim zweiten Experiment war das Ergebnis bereits bestimmt. Also
hätten die zwei Schirme am Ende jeder der zweiten Stern-Gerlach-Apparaturen jeweils nur einen Fleck. Ein Schirm hätte
alle Spin-up-Atome und ein Schirm hätte alle Spin-down-Atome. Für unser nächstes Experiment
beginnen wir mit einem Strahl aus reinen Spin-up-Atomen. Mit einem echten physikalischen Stern-Gerlach-Experiment könntest du das tun, indem du
sie durch eine Stern-Gerlach-Apparatur schickst und den nach unten abgelenkten Strahl blockierst, sodass alle nach oben abgelenkten Atome
Spin up sind. Jetzt schicken wir diesen Strahl durch eine weitere Stern-Gerlach-Apparatur, aber diesmal drehen wir die Magnete um 90°, sodass
der Feldgradient die Atome, die in diese Richtung fliegen, nach links oder rechts ablenkt. Würden wir
einen Fleck oder zwei oder etwas völlig anderes sehen? Für dieses Experiment
führen wir den folgenden Circuit auf Qiskit aus. Wir starten im Null-Zustand, da unser Atomstrahl in diesem Experiment alle
Spin up sind. Dann tauscht dieses Hadamard-Gate die X- und Z-Koordinaten aus, sodass es den Effekt hat, die
Stern-Gerlach-Apparatur zu drehen. Jetzt messen wir die Spin-Projektion links oder rechts statt oben oder unten. Hier erhalten wir
das Messhistogramm, das so aussieht. Wir können also sehen, dass der Spin entlang X ebenfalls nur zwei Werte annehmen kann,
die wir Spin links und Spin rechts nennen können. Dieses Experiment zeigt also, dass wenn du die X-Projektion eines Spins misst,
der zuvor als Spin up entlang Z gemessen wurde, er mit gleicher Wahrscheinlichkeit Spin links oder rechts sein wird. Lass uns das
ein letztes Mal mit der klassischen Erwartung vergleichen, um den Unterschied wirklich hervorzuheben. Klassisch, erinnere dich daran, dass ich
gesagt habe, wenn der kleine atomare Stabmagnet senkrecht zum Magnetfeldgradienten der Apparatur steht,
sollte die Kraft auf das Atom null sein. Es sollte nicht nach oben oder unten abgelenkt werden. In diesem Fall sehen wir nur einen einzigen Fleck in der
Mitte des Schirms. Stattdessen sehen wir zwei Flecke. Also hat die Hälfte der Atome Spin links und die Hälfte Spin rechts, obwohl
sie zuvor als up gemessen wurden. Also aus quantenmechanischer Sicht, obwohl es verlockend sein mag,
Spin up mit einem Vektor, der nach oben zeigt, und Spin down mit einem, der nach unten zeigt, gleichzusetzen, ist es nicht so einfach, wie wir aus dem
letzten Experiment sehen können. Um wirklich zu verstehen, was hier passiert, müssen wir tiefer in die Themen
Quanten-Superposition und Messung eintauchen, was ein Video für einen anderen Tag sein wird. So wie wir mit mehr
Fragen darüber zurückbleiben, wie genau Quantenmechanik funktioniert, so ging es auch Stern und Gerlach. Ihr Experiment erklärte nicht
alles, aber es trug maßgeblich dazu bei, die Quantenmechanik als wesentlich für das Verständnis der natürlichen
Welt zu etablieren. Es war eines der wichtigsten grundlegenden Experimente der Quantenmechanik, das sowohl die Quantisierung
des Drehimpulses bewies als auch Beweise für eine neue fundamentale Eigenschaft der Natur namens Spin lieferte. Um wirklich mit den
Regeln der Quantenwelt zu ringen und sie zu verstehen, mussten Physiker wie Stern und Gerlach sich die Hände schmutzig machen, indem sie
Experimente entwarfen, Vorhersagen machten und manchmal falsch lagen. Es gibt wirklich keinen Ersatz dafür, Dinge selbst auszuprobieren.
Also wenn du dich selbst an einigen echten Quantenexperimenten versuchen willst, geh zum Stern-Gerlach-Modul,
das in der Beschreibung verlinkt ist. Danke fürs Zuschauen, und bis zum nächsten Mal.